a nuclear power plant in the path of  hurricane Florence is offline this  morning while the storm slams the  Carolinas crews shut down the Duke  Energy Brunswick nuclear plant in  Southport North Carolina yesterday it's  it's roughly four miles inland and was  expected to be blasted by  hurricane-force winds Florence could  dump more than two feet of rain in the  area and the Brunswick plants reactors  they share the same design as the plant  in Fukushima Japan that exploded and  leaked following an earthquake and  tsunami in 2011 the facility is  reportedly designed to withstand  category 5 wind gusts of up to 200 miles  an hour  Duke Energy says operators will stay on  site during the storm  to monitor the plant